you know wrong used to produce uranium
at ninety-three percent in Richmond that
was brought down to twenty percent now
three point six seven percent how how
landmark is this deal how much of a
breakthrough is it this deal is adequate
to ensure that they won't build nuclear
weapons in my opinion so three point six
seven percent what does that mean what
can that power back end that's ordinary
reactor fuel in most countries of the
world that's what most of the reactors
in the United States run on and reactors
in Russia and China and almost every
other country has that as the normal
enrichment for nuclear power and yet you
think the two most important words in
this deal are what you know you take
this enormous document and look at
article 15 and it says Iran will allow I
aea to monitor online enrichment
measurement and use electronic seals
those are the important words that means
that we can look at every pipe in the
system and look at the enrichment going
around in their in their isotope
separation cascade so online monitoring
and yet Jordan I wonder from you there's
gonna be huge pressure on the United
States to surveil Iran's activities
could we see more Stuxnet spots Stuxnet
style spying yeah you know to
interesting direction because you know
well certainly we have there's going to
be less incentive you know on the on the
US part two to pursue destructive cyber
attacks because there is this this deal
in place you know you can't imagine a
situation in which the White House would
go to Fort Meade you know and tell them
to stop spying on Iran to make sure that
this is this deal is proceeding as
planned in fact you could imagine it
being the opposite that there could be
increased cyberspying not with a
destructive aim but in terms of
surveillance and intelligence gathering
you know you can't imagine a situation
in which that stops or slows liam what's
your take and he Stuxnet was designed
specifically to sabotage Iranian nuclear
facilities are we going to see more
malicious malware are we gonna see other
kinds of surveillance
that's right sucks and was specifically
designed for sabotage so we don't know
exactly who would still have motivation
to sabotage the centrifuges but there
could still be that possibility out
there but it's more likely that we'll
see espionage at this particular time to
particularly see if the what was
promised in the negotiations is being
performed and the deal is being held up
so we do expect to see additional
espionage in fact since stuck set was
released five years ago we've seen a
huge increase in espionage threats in
general backed by governments so we
expect that to continue what's your take
on this professor in terms of whether
this could lead to increased cyber
activity Stuxnet my way of looking at it
was largely a failure it it's sort of
like telling all the taxicab drivers in
New York City to drive at 90 miles an
hour across town and in come to a
complete stop it was it was cold written
two controllers that quickly was found
out about it didn't really destroy that
many centrifuges and it morphed into
something that did more damage here and
yet on that note Jordan you said that
that this was like the gold standard for
hackers how does a program like that get
developed and how would it happen if it
was done again today sure you know I
mean to this day you know Stuxnet really
was kind of the model for the most one
of the most advanced cyber attacks we've
seen you know and the kind of the scale
of it the ambition of it was certainly
beyond anything we'd seen before
publicly at least but it did have the
fatal flaw that we discussed which is it
got out that's the only reason we know
about it and it just goes to show that
you know programs like that when you're
dealing with this this type of activity
there are a lot of imperfections and
there are a lot of unknowns that need to
be worked out you know and a big
question mark around Stuxnet was you
know we don't know where else the US and
Israel you have used similar programs
have you know have those governments use
them against North Korea you know have
they use them again in other parts of
the world there's still lots of
unanswered questions there so why
wouldn't expect to see a sucks nut you
know kind of part two you know we could
certainly expect to see lots more
surveillance you know if anything that
that amount would just increase
so Liam you know what's your take on
what else we could see and how it might
compare to you know the way that cyber
attacks at the time of Stuxnet Stuxnet
were planned and executed right well the
the resources that we use to create
Stuxnet they haven't disappeared so
those resources are still available and
they're more than likely being put in
two new programs now and actually what
we've seen most recently we've seen a
lot of I spin at around the summits and
negotiations so the g8 summit the g20
and particularly the p5 plus one we've
most recently seen the tax where hotels
where the negotiators were likely to be
staying hotels around the negotiation
venues were being hacked so that
attackers could spy on the people who
are staying in those hotels so that's
the sort of level of espionage we're
looking at right now and that's what we
know about and there's probably a lot
more going on that we are not aware of
right now and it's going to be a lot
more going on in the future so clearly
any sort of international negotiations
are very highly prized espionage target
and quickly professor what are you going
to be watching now now that this deal is
done I'm going to be watching what the
engineers and scientists actually have
access to and what they're doing and
seeing if there's going to be able to to
verify all the terms in the street